♪ ♪
>> Bret: OVERSEAS NOW, NEW
QUESTIONS TONIGHT ABOUT HOW’D
NORTH KOREA HAS BEEN AFFECTED BY
THE CORONAVIRUS.
THEY COME IN MID-CONFUSION OVER
THE HEALTH OF THE COUNTRY’S
DICTATOR.
SENIOR FOREIGN AFFAIRS
GREG PALKOT HAS THE STORY.
>> THE MYSTERY OF COVID-19 AND
NORTH KOREA CONTINUES TO CREATE
IT DESPITE BEING SURROUNDED BY
COUNTRIES WHICH HAD BEEN
INFESTED WITH THE CORONAVIRUS,
NORTH KOREA, A NATION WITH ONE
OF THE FIRST HEALTH SYSTEMS IN
THE WORLD HAS SAID PUBLICLY AND
HAS ZERO CASES.
>> THEY ARE STRICTLY
RE-EXAMINING IF THERE’S ANY
PLACE WHERE INFECTION CAN GET IN
AND TAKING PRECAUTIONS ACCORDING
TO A WELL THOUGHT OUT PLAN.
>> RECENTLY, AND EMERGED
INTERNAL LECTURES GIVEN TO THE
NORTH PEOPLE BY THE GOVERNMENT
INDICATED THAT THERE ARE
INFECTIONS AROUND THE COUNTRY.
CONFIRMING REPORTS OF DEATHS
AMONG SOLDIERS, PRISON INMATES,
AND THOSE FROM PYONGYANG ALL
DESPITE THE GOVERNOR’S CLOSING
OFF BORDERS AND WATCHING TOUGH
MEASURES AIMED AT SAVING LIVES.
PERHAPS, SAVING THE KIM JONG UN
REGIME.
>> ACTING AS IF IT’S SURVIVAL IS
THREATENED BY THAT.
>> MOVES IMPACTING THE NORTH’S
WEAK ECONOMY AND FRONTAL SOCIETY
CAN FURTHER DESTABILIZE THE
NUCLEAR ARM ROGUE NATION.
AS FOR KIM JONG UN, REPORTED TO
HAVE A HEART OPERATION AND
POSSIBLY A BAD RECOVERY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP THINKS HE’S ALL
RIGHT.
>> AS A GOOD RELATIONSHIP WITH
KIM JONG UN AND I HOPE HE’S
OKAY.
>> OTHERS SAY THAT KIM WAS IN
CONTROL BLEEDING THEM TO THINK
THAT THE LATEST TWO WEEK ABSENCE
MIGHT NOT HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH THE OPERATION.
>> CHAIRMAN CAN MIGHT BE
SHELTERING IN PYONGYANG AND THE